# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi fürnes neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
Auf der Suche nach dem Glück
nimmt der Mensch weite Wege auf sich.
Den Himmel auf Erden vermuten wir
meist dort, wo wir nicht sind -
in der Ferne.
Jahr für Jahr wandern Tausende
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer aus
und beginnen im Ausland
ein neues Leben.
Wir haben Auswanderer begleitet.
Vor einem Jahr suchten sie ihr Glück
in Costa Rica, in Australien
und auf Kreta.
Oh, mein Gott.
Marcel Buholzer
und seine Frau Beatrice
verkauften kurzentschlossen
ihr Haus im Kanton Solothurn.
Sie wollten raus aus dem Alltagstrott
und wanderten nach Griechenland aus.
We are new here.
No English.
- New Kreta.
Okay, thank you.
Auf Kreta eröffneten sie
eine Rock- und Bluesbar.
Eine nervenaufreibende Zeit.
Sag doch,
wenn man dir etwas helfen kann!
Was willst du helfen?
Die Endstufe für die Bassboxen
geht nicht.
Familie Landolt aus Glarus übernahm
in Australien ein Ferienresort
und wollte dort
mit den Aborigines zusammenarbeiten.
* Der Mann murmelt. *
Doch die Finanzierung der Anlage
war eine grosse Schwierigkeit.
Es kann nicht sein, dass ich
elf Monate in der Schweiz bin
und einen Monat hier.
Friday Creek.
- Galnyamba!
Das Happy End
schien in greifbarer Nähe.
Aber alles kam anders.
Wir haben nun keine legale Basis
mehr für unseren Antrag.
Aber der Vertrag ist abgelaufen.
Verkäufer Bill verlor die Geduld.
Er klagte vor Gericht
und die Landolts mussten weg.
Wir haben am Anfang
einen Kaufvertrag unterzeichnet.
Ich denke, das war ein Fehler,
den wir nicht hätten machen sollen.
Perfekte Wellen,
das ganze Jahr hindurch.
In Santa Teresa
an der Westküste Costa Ricas
wagten Mike Wiedmer
und Nicole Gerstner
den Sprung in ein neues Leben -
zusammen mit ihren drei Kindern.
Hello!
Samstagnachmittag.
Um diese Zeit
hätte sich Mike vor zwei Jahren
um die Kunden in seinem Laden
in Thun kümmern müssen
und Snowboards verkauft.
Heute hat er viel mehr Zeit -
für seine Familie
und den Skater-Park,
die neue Attraktion in Santa Teresa.
Kinu, wenn du hier vorne bist,
kannst du keinen Olli machen.
Du musst nach hinten stehen
und dann in die Knie und dann ...
Die Familie wollte der Hektik
des Schweizer Alltags entfliehen.
Aber die alte Heimat
ganz aufgegeben haben sie nicht.
Gerade am Anfang
ist es nicht immer einfach gewesen.
Und jetzt ist es ...
Thun ist immer die Heimat,
wird auch immer die Heimat sein.
Aber hier fühle ich mich jetzt
auch sehr daheim.
Es sind jetzt halt zwei Orte.
Wie schwierig
der Start in Costa Rica sein würde,
hätten sie auf den ersten Blick
nicht vermutet.
Schauen wir mit der Familie
noch einmal zurück auf eine Zeit,
als sie das gute alte Leben
hinter sich liessen.
In Zürich machen sich die Thuner
bereit für den Abflug.
Anderthalb Jahre haben sie
auf diesen Tag hingearbeitet.
Doch der letzte Schritt
zu ihrem grossen Traum
fällt ihnen schwerer als gedacht.
Abschied nehmen
von Freunden und Familie ...
Auf eine Art ein Scheissgefühl,
aber wir wollte es ja so.
* Sentimentale Klänge *
Sich von den Freunden verabschieden,
ist für Nicole besonders schwierig.
Tschüss und vielen Dank.
Die Freunde sind ihre Familie, denn
ihre Eltern sind bereits verstorben.
Tschüss zusammen!
Nun gibt es kein Zurück.
Du lässt dich auf etwas ein
und hast eigentlich keinen ...
Einen Plan hast du vielleicht,
aber du weisst ja nicht.
Auf so vielen Ebenen
kann etwas schieflaufen.
Ich glaube, es ist auch ...
- Das war für mich das Schlimme.
Jetzt gehst du und ah ...
Dann wurde es mir bewusst.
Das war so ein Markpunkt,
an dem du irgendwie
mit der Vergangenheit abschliesst.
Dann gehst du über den Zoll,
und dann kommt die Zukunft.
Von da an
schaust du nur noch nach vorne.
Auswandern und sich gleich
alleine durchschlagen müssen,
so hat sich Nicole das
Familienabenteuer nicht vorgestellt.
Mit Joaquin und seiner Schwester
fährt sie nach Santa Teresa voraus.
Mike und Joshua mussten
in der Hauptstadt San Jose bleiben.
Mike wartet auf einen Geländewagen,
den er von der Schweiz aus gekauft
hat und der noch nicht fertig ist.
Für die ersten Monate haben die
Auswanderer zwei Häuschen gemietet.
Sie haben sie im Internet gefunden.
Jetzt, da Nicole die Unterkunft
zum ersten Mal in Realität sieht,
macht sich Ernüchterung breit.
Man sieht es mir schon an.
Gibt es hier Licht?
Nein, das ist momentan
nicht angeschlossen.
Was Nicole vorher auch nicht wusste:
Die Bungalows liegen ausserhalb
des Dorfes, mitten im Dschungel.
Es gibt nur ein kleines Problem.
Ich kann den Schlüssel nicht finden.
Aber morgen bringe ich ihn.
Was ist mit dem Licht?
Ah, das Licht mache ich später.
Okay, pura vida Costa Rica.
Vamos!
Costa Rica, pura vida! Venga!
Pura vida, das volle Leben.
Die flotten Sprüche des Verwalters
können nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen,
dass die beiden Häuser
nicht eben paradiesisch sind.
Weinst du? Oh, Schatz.
In der Schweiz
hätte ich es viel schöner gefunden.
Ich möchte nämlich nicht hier sein,
hier oben.
Habt ihr Hunger?
Es ist so abgelegen,
es ist wirklich extrem abgelegen.
Im Moment kann ich
überhaupt nicht ehrlich sein.
Das geht nicht, weil ich
die Kinder um mich herum habe.
Obwohl ich viel mehr zu sagen hätte.
Ich bin da, ist alles gut ...
Ich bin hier.
Ja, da haben wir Lehrgeld bezahlt.
Weisst du, nach zwei Jahren hier
würde ich das auch anders sehen.
Ja, mittlerweile
kann man darüber lachen.
Ja, lachen ...
- Doch, man kann darüber lachen.
Aber wenn du
aus der Schweiz kommst ...
... dann ist das wirklich Horror.
Das ist der Lounge-Bereich hier.
Ich glaube,
da würde ich mich nie hinsetzen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie fest das lebt.
Ich hatte das Ankommen
anders geplant.
Wir haben uns darauf vorbereitet,
aber es ist wirklich alles
anders gekommen, als wir wollten.
Nach fünf Wochen im Provisorium
ist es endlich so weit.
Mike und Nicole sind unterwegs
zu ihrem neuen Zuhause.
Die Villa mit Pool
haben sie vor wenigen Tagen gekauft.
Ich ziehe meine Hose
schon im Auto aus.
Juhu!
Endlich.
Nun scheint die Familie endlich
im Tropenparadies angekommen zu sein.
Ein gutes Gefühl,
ein wunderschönes Gefühl.
Das, was wir immer
mit Costa Rica verbunden haben:
die Natur, die Lebensfreude,
die Musik und das Essen und alles.
Es hat bis jetzt auch gestimmt,
aber immer mit dem Wermutstropfen,
ohne ein Daheim zu sein.
Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl,
dass es mich tief innen berührt.
Ich glaube, es ist gut, sehr gut.
An der Hermosa Valley School
beginnt das neue Schuljahr.
Hinstehen Kinder!
Jetzt wird in Kolone gestanden.
Was machst du für ein Gesicht?
Erster Schultag
für Joaquin und Joshua.
Lächeln!
Und für die kleine Joseline:
Einschulung.
Die neuen Mitschüler
kommen aus der ganzen Welt.
Und die Lehrer
sprechen nur Spanisch oder Englisch.
Sechs Knaben und drei Mädchen.
- Nur drei Mädchen.
Ich komme nachher wieder.
Ich verteile nur die Kleinen.
Tochter Joseline ging in Thun
noch in den Kindergarten.
Dort war sie bestens integriert
und hatte jede Menge Freunde.
Ich bleibe da. Ja, ja.
Jetzt ist es mir gerade
recht mulmig.
Ich hoffe einfach, es kommt gut,
es gefällt ihr.
Wem?
- Dir.
In Costa Rica
wird Joseline eingeschult.
Sie kennt niemanden
und versteht kaum ein Wort.
Nicole sorgt sich v.a.
um ihre beiden kleineren Kinder.
Sie hofft,
dass sie den Tag gut überstehen.
Willst du die Mütze abnehmen?
Ich schaue nachher noch mal rein.
Ist gut? - Ja.
Schatz, komm, löse dich!
Jetzt musst du dich lösen,
sonst kommt es nicht gut.
Ist gut Chineli, freust du dich?
Es kommt gut.
Wenn man es jetzt so sieht,
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen,
dass ich am Anfang,
ja fast Angst hatte.
Am Anfang hatte ich wirklich Angst.
Ich sehe es mir selber an.
Ja, ich hatte auch Angst.
Dann hat sich das so ergeben.
Mir war es peinlich.
- Peinlich.
Jetzt ist es so normal.
Du gehörst dazu und kennst alle.
Damals haben wir
noch niemanden gekannt.
Und jetzt bist du einfach voll drin.
Komm Leu, komm!
Mike und Nicole
machen sich an die Arbeit.
Sie wollen auf ihrem neuen Grundstück
Ferienhäuser bauen.
Wie weit möchtest du
mit den Flip Flops ins Gebüsch?
Zusätzlich zu ihrer Villa haben die
beiden noch 5'000 m2 Land gekauft.
Was ich gerne mal
ausgemessen möchte,
ist die Länge des Plantels.
Warte, du musst nicht zu weit!
Auf diesem Terrain
hätten locker zwei Bungalows Platz.
Ein wenig gross.
- Was?
Das gibt ein grosses Bungalow.
Ja, das gibt ein grosses,
langes Bungalow.
Wie viele Bungalows es werden sollen,
darüber sind sich die beiden
noch nicht einig.
Klar ist aber, womit sie
ihr Projekt beginnen wollen.
Mit einem kleinen Haus,
das versteckt unter Palmen
auf ihrem Grundstück liegt.
Hola!
- Buenas!
Queremos mirar un poco. Bueno?
- (Frau) Está bien.
Gracias.
- Hola, como estás?
Ihr Problem:
Das Haus ist noch bewohnt.
Hier lebt eine Familie aus Nicaragua.
Carla mit zwei Kindern
und ihrem Mann Carmelo.
Er war beim Vorbesitzer Hausmeister.
Ja, weisst du, das ist schon ...
Du darfst nicht so abschätzig sein.
- Nein, nein.
Ich schaue nur das Bauliche an.
Was?
- Ich komme mir gerade so mies vor.
Wieso? Spricht sie gut Berndeutsch?
Nein, aber wir schauen das Haus an
und sagen ...
Na und? So ist das Leben.
So ist es.
Podemos entrar? Gracias.
Lachst du?
Die Hausmeisterfamilie
hat kein festes Einkommen mehr -
jetzt, wo Nicole und Mike
die Villa gekauft haben.
Bis jetzt war es etwas anderes,
da konnte ich sagen:
"Ja, ich kann denen ja
quasi nicht helfen
oder nichts daran ändern
und nichts machen."
Und jetzt gehört es uns,
und wir machen es noch schlimmer.
Jetzt müssen die weg von hier.
Ja, das lässt dich sicher
nicht kalt, definitiv nicht.
Andererseits, wenn du in der Schweiz
als Mieter eine Kündigung bekommst,
musst du auch ausziehen.
Hier ist eigentlich nichts anders.
Obwohl sie ganz klar
ärmer sind als wir,
ist die Situation genau gleich.
Nein, kalt gelassen
hat es uns nicht.
Wir sorgten dafür, dass er
eine feste Anstellung bei mir hat.
Wir haben zu ihnen geschaut
und ihnen sicher über
das normale Mass hinaus geholfen.
Er hat bei uns gearbeitet usw.
Wir haben versucht, ihnen Hand
zu reichen, wo es nur möglich war.
Carmelo durfte sich auf dem
Grundstück von Mike und Nicole
eine neue Bleibe bauen -
für sich, Carla und die Kinder.
Mike hat ihnen
das Baumaterial bezahlt.
Die Schweizer fühlen sich für
die kleine Familie verantwortlich.
Und: Mit Carmelos Hilfe
bessert Mike sein Spanisch auf.
Es el primer machete que compro.
- Machete.
Carne, tac.
Como Rambo.
Gracias, Carmelo.
Wo Carmelo bisher wohnte, steht
kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen.
Unter Aufsicht von Architekt Ghadi
soll ein stilvolles Gästehaus
entstehen.
Als gelernter Zimmermann
wollte Mike selber Hand anlegen.
Doch dieser Plan ging nicht auf.
Ich habe angefangen, indem ich
mit Carmelo die Fundamente gemacht
und alles betoniert habe.
Ich habe aber gemerkt, dass wir
zu zweit nicht vorwärtskamen.
Für mich ist es relativ schwierig,
mit einem schlechten Spanisch
das richtige Material
am richtigen Ort zu bekommen.
Und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich mich
auch kaputt gemacht habe.
Und dass es v.a.
auch ewig gedauert hätte.
Deshalb haben wir uns entschieden,
Ghadi und seine Jungs herzuholen.
So ist es schneller fertig,
wir können es schneller vermieten
und es kommt auch schneller
wieder Geld rein.
Vámonos!
Einfach nur zuschauen
ist für Mike immer noch ungewohnt.
Auch die kleine Joseline
kommt nicht richtig an in Costa Rica.
Sie hat Heimweh
und vermisst die Schweiz.
Zur Ablenkung
darf die Sechsjährige zum Reitkurs,
zusammen mit ihrem Bruder Joaquin.
Hallo!
- Hello!
Joachim, Joseline,
das ist Floriella.
Sie spricht Spanisch und Englisch.
- Okay, wow!
Marian? Marianne?
- No, Mariana.
Mariana.
Mama, komm!
Tschüss, bis nachher!
Hasta luego, bis nachher!
Esto me lo quiero quitar.
Nicole hofft, dass Tochter Joseline
beim Reiten ihr Heimweh vergisst
und eine Freundin findet.
Es tut einfach weh,
wenn du siehst, wie sie leidet,
das tut sie manchmal wirklich.
Aber zuerst wollte ich
dagegen ankämpfen und sagen:
"Es ist nicht so schlimm
und es kommt dann schon."
Ich wollte sie beruhigen, trösten.
Und jetzt sind wir
einfach so weit und sagen:
"Wenn du Heimweh hast, weinst du,
dann hören wir ein Liedchen,
und dann weinen wir zusammen."
Das gehört dazu. Ich hoffe,
irgendwann wird es weniger.
Aber trotz aller Schwierigkeiten: Die
Familie gibt sich nicht geschlagen.
Speziell in Bezug auf die Kinder
braucht es Mut, um das zu machen.
Du weisst nie, wie es für sie geht.
Andererseits weisst du auch nicht,
wie es für dich selber ist.
Es ist auch für uns zwei
nicht immer einfach gewesen.
Es hat sich jetzt eingependelt,
es ist einfacher geworden.
Aber am Anfang hat man sich da
schon manchmal hinterfragt.
Es war nicht immer alles
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Ganz klar nicht!
Endlich ist es geschafft.
Simsalabim!
Nach vier Monaten Bauzeit
ist der erste Ferienbungalow fertig.
Er hat zwei Schlafzimmer
und Platz für fünf Personen.
Mike hat extra
Nachttische geschreinert.
Ich möchte auch schauen.
Zu hoch?
Nein, wenn du unten noch
eines mehr hinstellst, ist es gut.
Das Paar
hat sein erstes Etappenziel erreicht.
Stolz? Doch ich bin stolz.
Es ist ein gutes Gefühl.
Und ich mache es auch extrem gerne,
wenn Gäste kommen,
Freude haben und gerne hier sind.
Das ist für mich nicht Arbeit,
überhaupt nicht.
Es war noch nie Arbeit.
Die Vermietung des Ferienbungalows
ist inzwischen prächtig angelaufen.
Und: Sohn Joshua ist 15 geworden.
Die Familie muss sich entscheiden,
ob er eine Berufslehre macht.
Ein Grund,
in die Schweiz zurückzukehren?
Auch Marcel und seine Frau Beatrice
wollten ihren Traum leben.
Sie eröffneten
die eigene Rock- und Bluesbar.
In der Schweiz
kündigten sie ihre sicheren Jobs
und wanderten nach Griechenland aus.
Aber so schön hätte sich das Paar
ihr neues Leben nie vorgestellt.
Seit Anfang 2015
wohnen sie in dieser Villa.
Wir haben unsere Ecke gefunden.
Mit dem Ausblick, den du hier hast,
auch am Abend oder am frühen Morgen,
wenn ich heimkomme,
dann kannst du auf der Terrasse
noch ein Glas Wein trinken,
runterfahren, und eine halbe Stunde
später gehst du dich hinlegen.
Dann bist du am Morgen wieder fit.
So!
Die Villa liegt nicht nur näher
an der Bar als die vorherige Wohnung.
Sie ist auch noch günstig.
Rund 1'300 Euro kostet sie im Monat.
Drinnen macht Ehefrau Trix Bretzeli.
Das Süssgebäck ist der Renner
bei Marcels Gästen.
Ich bin froh,
dass das so gut ankommt.
Wir haben
schon in der Schweiz gesagt,
dass wir irgendetwas machen wollen,
was anders ist
als bei den anderen Bars.
Und da ist das Thema Bretzeli
gefallen, weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
man kann nicht etwas mit Schokolade
machen, wenn es so warm ist.
Und dann etwas,
was man gut vorbereiten kann.
Und eben, das kann man wirklich gut.
Aber momentan reicht die Zeit
nicht einmal zum Vorbereiten,
weil die Schachteln
immer wieder leer sind.
Für mich heisst das, dass ich
wieder von vorne beginnen muss.
Ich muss noch das Eisen ausstecken.
Sonst brennt es hier drinnen.
Danke!
Mit Fleiss und Durchhaltevermögen
haben Marcel und Trix
ihr Glück gefunden.
Ein neues Haus,
ein traumhafter Ausblick
und direkt am Hafen
von Agios Nikolaos die eigene Bar.
Hallo, zusammen!
- Guten Tag miteinander!
Schöne Ferien.
- Herzlich willkommen bei uns.
Wunderbar!
Geniesst ihr es?
- Ja, ja.
Sehr schön. Mit den Langlaufski
geht es gut hier. Es ist flach.
Die Gastfreundschaft
haben Marcel und Trix im Blut.
Aber miteinander hatten sie es
zu Beginn ihrer Auswanderung
nicht immer einfach.
Das neue Leben von Marcel Buholzer
und seiner Frau Trix
beginnt im Dunkeln.
Im Dorf Elounda
beziehen sie eine Wohnung.
Sie haben diese Unterkunft
während ihres letzten Aufenthalts
in Kreta gemietet.
Hier haben wir aber
noch ein Durcheinander.
Eine Spedition hat bereits
den gesamten Haushalt der Buholzers
in die neue Wohnung gebracht.
Rund 1'000 Euro pro Monat
bezahlen sie für die vier Zimmer.
Hier ist es auch kalt.
Trix wusste genau, wie sie ihr Nest
in Griechenland einrichten möchte.
Einige dieser Möbel hat sie
extra noch in der Schweiz gekauft.
Irgendwie haben wir uns
mit den Möbeln verkalkuliert.
Du hast gesagt, wenn du
die Zimmer siehst, weisst du wie.
Eben, ja!
- Ja, ich weiss schon wie.
Die Zimmer sind nicht geschrumpft.
Du hast zu wenig mitgedacht.
- Du sagtest, du wüsstest wie.
Du hast doch die Betten ausgewählt.
Hier habe ich mir
einen langen Gang vorgestellt.
Und jetzt frage ich mich,
was wir mit den Kommoden
und dem ganzen Zeug machen.
Eben, ja.
Sie hatte einfach
alles anders im Kopf,
und es musste einfach sein.
Sie konnte nicht warten,
bis wir hier sind.
Das hatte sie auch
grösser in Erinnerung.
Jetzt hat es nur noch Platz für
zwei Nachttische und fertig Schluss.
Die Einbauschränke sind da,
also was willst du noch mehr.
Ich sehe dann über den Berg,
wenn die Schachteln versorgt sind.
Eben, und jetzt siehst du auch,
warum wir hier oben keinen Platz
haben für die Schachteln.
Ja, am Anfang haben wir
viel mehr gestritten.
Nein, nicht gestritten, aber eben,
sie hatte ihre Meinung
und ich meine.
Ich bin eher der, der dann sagt:
Es ist halt so im Moment,
da müssen wir durch.
Und sie hat das Gefühl,
es muss gerade sofort sein.
Da kommt halt die Schweizerin,
die in ihr steckt, hervor.
Das ist so. Wenn ich etwas sage,
dann muss es ...
Ich war schon immer so:
Ich kann nicht auf morgen warten,
es muss gleich erledigt werden.
Ich habe
sehr grosse Schwierigkeiten,
mich heimisch zu fühlen,
wenn ich mich nicht wohlfühle.
Es ist Vorsaison.
Seit sechs Wochen wohnt Marcel
Buholzer mit seiner Frau auf Kreta.
Freunde haben die Solothurner noch
keine gefunden. Dafür aber ein Lokal.
Seit eineinhalb Jahren
ist es geschlossen.
Das ist jetzt die Bar,
die ich übernehme.
Es ist zwar noch viel zu machen,
aber das kommt gut.
Innen ist noch unaufgeräumt,
aber ...
Man muss neu dekorieren,
und hier werden neue Platten gelegt.
Hier gibt es
eine neue Schrift drauf:
The Zep - Aquarius.
Und die Aussicht von hier ist ...
Am Morgen scheint die Sonne.
Also es wird sicher
eine schöne Ecke werden.
Schon am nächsten Tag ist es so weit.
Marcel stellt die Weichen
für ihr neues Leben.
Trix trägt in ihrer Handtasche
ein dickes Bündel Geldscheine.
So, jetzt geht es bergauf.
Ganz viel Geld neben dem Brot,
schau!
Sehr viel Geld.
Ich packe es gleich wieder weg.
Nicht dass ich noch
überfallen werde.
Lange hast du es nicht mehr.
- Ja, eben nicht.
Du bist es gleich los.
- So ist es.
Mit dem Geld gehts zum Anwalt.
Dort unterzeichnen Marcel und Trix
den Pachtvertrag.
Good morning!
- Kalimera!
Kalimera!
Der Anwalt erwartet das Ehepaar
bereits im Büro in seinem Wohnhaus.
Trix wird herzlich von Ella,
der Maklerin, begrüsst.
Sie hat die Bar vermittelt.
Setzt du dich hierher.
Du musst ja übersetzen.
Siehst du,
jetzt bist du es schon los.
Das ist schnell gegangen.
- Schon ist es fort.
Das Geld bekommt der Vorbesitzer
der Bar als Ablöse.
Für das Inventar
müssen sie 40'000 Euro bezahlen.
Wahnsinnig viel Geld.
Ich hoffe immer noch,
das Geld ist gut angelegt.
Aber es geht mir nur darum,
dass er nicht verarscht wird.
Und nicht 40'000 Euro weg sind
und nachher läuft die Bar nicht.
Oder was auch immer.
Es geht mir nur um ihn.
Ich darf gar nicht hinschauen.
Und schon kommen die Tränen.
Da tröstet dich die Kleine.
Also im Nachhinein
hat es sich sicher gelohnt,
dass er die Bar übernommen hat.
Das ist so.
Ich habe mir es vielleicht
erst ein Jahr später vorgestellt,
aber jetzt ist es einfach so,
und ich habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Und da gebe ich ihm sicher Recht:
Es war der Zeitpunkt für die Bar.
Er hat es schon richtig gemacht.
Ein neuer Lebensabschnitt beginnt.
Marcel ist nun
stolzer Besitzer einer Bar.
Ohne Musik geht nichts.
Das ist Joe Bonamassa -
der Bluesking.
* Energischer Bluesrock *
In sechs Wochen
möchte Marcel erste Gäste bewirten.
Bis dahin haben er und Ehefrau Trix
die Aufgaben klar verteilt.
Also im Moment ist Trix für
daheim zuständig und ich für hier.
Sie wird dann kommen,
wenn wir die Gläser waschen
und das Ganze
noch mehr auf Vordermann bringen.
Ganz alleine schafft Marcel
den Umbau aber doch nicht.
Er hat Barman Nico eingestellt.
Der Grieche hat früher hier
hinter dem Tresen gearbeitet.
Nico, alles okay?
Yes, good.
Das letzte Bier wurde in diesem Lokal
vor eineinhalb Jahren gezapft.
Seitdem hat sich manch
unliebsamer Bewohner eingenistet.
Dass es so schnell geht,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich auch nicht, das ist logisch.
Innerhalb von sechs Wochen eine Bar
kaufen, übernehmen und eröffnen ...
Das ist auch für Griechenland
ein Weltwunder,
dass das
in sechs Wochen geschafft wurde.
Komm doch du
ein wenig mehr hier rüber!
Unsere Vorhänge!
Marcel hat einen anstrengenden
Arbeitstag in der Bar hinter sich.
Doch zu Hause ist für ihn
noch nicht Feierabend.
Ups, den habe ich
ein wenig verfehlt.
Wie?
- Ein wenig verfehlt.
Trix hat Vorhänge gekauft, mit denen
sie den Balkon verschönern möchte.
Moment!
War das eine schlaue Idee,
was wir jetzt gemacht haben?
Jetzt kann ich sie
fast nicht mehr zusammenfassen.
Auf keinen Fall mehr.
Hör zu,
ich bin jetzt doch verunsichert,
ob die Nägel
wieder weg müssen oder nicht.
Dann warten wir eben,
bis du dich entschieden hast.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist es anders gegangen, oder nicht?
Ja, es ist gut,
du kannst mir die Schnur geben.
Ah, Mutter, du.
Ich frage mich manchmal, was das
alles soll, das komische Zeug.
Ein Mann muss das nicht verstehen.
Das ist schön fürs Auge,
das verstehen Männer wirklich nicht.
Ich habe noch nie
eine Beziehung gesehen,
wo es keine Probleme
oder Streitereien gibt.
Das wäre ja wirklich ein Weltwunder.
Ich glaube,
das gehört bei uns einfach dazu.
Wir kennen einander seit 15 Jahren
und es ist immer
ein wenig gestritten worden.
Pünktlich zu Saisonbeginn eröffnet
Marcel seine Rock- und Bluesbar.
Alles ist bereit -
fast alles.
Sag doch, wenn man dir helfen kann!
Was willst du helfen?
Du kannst mir nicht helfen.
Die Endstufe für die Bassboxen
geht nicht.
Das muss einfach laufen, sonst
bringt man keinen rechten Ton raus.
Er sollte um 16.00 Uhr hier sein,
jetzt ist es 17.15 Uhr.
In 45 Min. öffnen wir.
Das ist die Hölle.
Ich wusste, dass er nervös ist.
- Siehst du hinten irgendwo Licht?
Ich?
- Ja.
Wo Licht?
- Hinten.
In der Mitte.
Jetzt ist da und da oben ...
Und die muss so blinken?
Ja.
- Gut!
Endlich kommt der Techniker mit dem
Verstärker, gerade noch rechtzeitig.
Wir haben lange auf dich gewartet.
Ich weiss.
Das war schon etwas Spezielles.
Das war ja die Bar, die wir wollten
oder die ich v.a. wollte.
Und dann ist endlich die Eröffnung,
sogar der Verstärker
funktionierte endlich.
Eine Rock- und Bluesbar ohne Musik
wäre nicht so gut angekommen.
Und da war ich natürlich nervös.
Und ja, das war schon emotional.
Partytime!
Die Eröffnungsparty
ist in vollem Gange.
Rund 100 Gäste
sind ins The Zep gekommen:
Freunde aus der Schweiz, Handwerker,
Nachbarn, aber auch einige Touristen.
Als Gastgeber und Chef will Marcel
natürlich eine Rede halten -
auf Griechisch.
Maklerin Ella hat sie übersetzt.
"Jassas, ke kaloss ..."
"Sto The Zep.
Do pro chumeno Aquarius."
Komm schon, du weisst doch,
wie es geht.
Hallo zusammen,
ich versuche es auf Griechisch.
Jassas, ke kaloss, jesate sto
The Zep. Do pro chumeno Aquarios.
Bravo!
Bravo, Bravo!
Jetzt könnte ich es
schon besser lesen.
Und nicht zuletzt vielen Dank auch
an Trix, meine wunderbare Frau,
für ihr Verständnis und die Geduld,
besonders in den letzten
sechs Wochen. Ich liebe dich.
Ich weine gleich wieder.
- Ja, du warst damals nahe dran.
Marcel und seine Gäste
haben eine lange Nacht vor sich.
Das ist schon ein Erlebnis,
das du nicht einfach wegsteckst.
Das wird auch
ewig in Erinnerung bleiben.
Das war mein Traum.
Für sie hat das Auswandern nach
Kreta auch gestimmt und von daher:
Wir haben ein schönes Leben,
tolle Aussichten für die Bar,
eine tolle Aussicht im Haus.
Also, was will man da bereuen?
Also für mich stimmt es auch 100%ig,
muss ich sagen.
Die Bar am Hafen - für Marcel ist ein
Herzenswunsch in Erfüllung gegangen.
Und die Beziehung hat gehalten.
Trix startet nun ihr eigenes
Geschäft. Aber dazu später.
Das Ferienhaus am Strand
ist nur eine Übergangslösung.
Gemietet haben es
Miriam Landolt und ihre Familie.
Der Alltag ist gleich geblieben.
Pro Tag zwei Waschmaschinen.
Im Juli 2015 mussten Landolts
die Ferienanlage Friday Creek
per Gerichtsbeschluss verlassen.
Sie konnten den vereinbarten
Kaufpreis nicht aufbringen.
Dabei hatte alles so gut angefangen.
Der Gästebetrieb lief
unter Miriams Führung immer besser.
Doch der Traum vom Leben und Arbeiten
mit den Aborigines ist jäh geplatzt.
Aufgeben wollen sie dennoch nicht.
Die Kinder haben sich gut eingelebt
und haben enge Freunde.
Sie wieder aus dem herauszureissen
und sagen,
wir gehen zurück in die Schweiz,
weil etwas nicht geklappt hat,
fände ich
eine falsche Message an die Kinder.
Wenn etwas nicht gleich so klappt,
wie du dachtest,
gehst du zurück in die Schweiz,
das ist keine Option.
Miriam und ihr Mann Jules
wollen weitermachen.
Bis es so weit ist, hält Miriam
den Familienalltag in Australien
so gut es geht am Laufen.
Sie hoffen, ihre Träume
im zweiten Anlauf umsetzen zu können.
Kann ich ein Röhrchen reintun?
Nein, der ist zu dick.
Er ist mit Mango.
Für Jannis und seine Geschwister
ist Coffs Harbour
bereits zur Heimat geworden.
Mirja, das Brot getoastet?
- Gerne.
Jannis, wo ist deine Lunchbox?
Es gibt einen sehr heissen Tag,
da brauchst du vielleicht
ein wenig Salz.
Einen Apfel und Chips? Nein!
Würdest du bitte noch
etwas anderes hineintun. - Nein!
Miriam möchte Abstand
zu Friday Creek gewinnen.
Im Ferienhaus am Strand
plant sie die nächsten Schritte.
Auf der anderen Seite der Erdkugel
ist Ehemann Jules
unterwegs zum Flughafen Zürich.
Er lebt und arbeitet
nach wie vor in der Schweiz.
Seine Familie in Australien
sieht er nur alle paar Monate.
Wir sind vielleicht nicht auf dem
direkten Weg ans Ziel gekommen.
Das wissen wir.
Aber ich denke,
das Ziel bleibt gleich.
Wir wissen nämlich,
dass unser Konzept Erfolg hatte.
Es hat funktioniert.
Es ist schade,
dass wir es nicht kaufen konnten.
Der Traum vom eigenen Ferienresort
und der Zusammenarbeit
mit den Ureinwohnern
hat vor mehr
als zwei Jahren begonnen.
Juni 2013: Das neue Zuhause
von Familie Landolt
liegt an der regenreichen
Ostküste Australiens,
nur wenige Autominuten
von Coffs Harbour entfernt.
Jules ist alleine
mit den vier Kindern vorausgereist.
Jungs, seid ihr wach?
Das Gelände ist 40 ha gross.
Neun Ferienbungalows stehen darauf
und das Wohnhaus der Familie.
Kostenpunkt: 2,4 Mio. Fr.
Das ist mehr
als die Glarner besitzen.
Und die Finanzierung
ist noch nicht geregelt.
Jules Frau will hier ihre Vision
vom Leben und Arbeiten
mit den Ureinwohnern verwirklichen.
Es ist jetzt noch speziell,
dass ich mit den Kindern vorausgehe.
Das Ganze ist ja insbesondere ...
... von ihr sehr geprägt.
Von ihrer Idee auch.
Für sie ist es
wie ein zweites Daheim.
Wie wenn das hier
eine zweite Familie wäre.
Kuckuck!
Buben, wir stehen schnell zusammen.
* Der Mann murmelt etwas. *
Rauch
soll die Neuankömmlinge schützen.
Eine alte Zeremonie der Aborigines.
Larry Kelly ist Stammesoberhaupt.
Für die Familie Landolt
ist er ein guter Freund,
aber auch ein Geschäftspartner.
Ah .... Hey!
Wir haben das Land
nicht alleine ausgewählt.
Das Land ist eigentlich zuerst
mit ihnen begangen worden.
Wir sind nie
alleine hierhergekommen,
ohne von ihnen begleitet zu werden.
Nicht wahr, Jelena?
- Ja.
Mit den Ureinwohnern wollen Landolts
Kulturprogramme anbieten.
* Die Kinder schreien. *
In der Schweiz geht das Leben für
Ehefrau Miriam seinen gewohnten Gang.
Sie wäre gerne bei ihrer Familie,
aber als Schulleiterin
ist sie noch sechs Wochen
an ihren Arbeitsvertrag gebunden.
Die Auswanderung
fordert für sie gleich zu Beginn
ein grosses Opfer.
Es ist das erste Mal, das die Kinder
nicht um mich herum sind.
Sie waren immer um mich herum.
Ich glaube, sie haben
einen Teil von mir mitgenommen.
Ich fühle sich so, wie wenn mir
ein Körperteil fehlen würde. Ja.
Im Ferienresort Friday Creek macht
sich Ehemann Jules an die Arbeit.
Die neun Ferienhäuser
hat eine Freundin der Familie
vorübergehend verwaltet.
I turn the fridge on ...
Janette Blainey zeigt, wie sie
die Häuser für Gäste vorbereitet.
In Zukunft macht das Familie Landolt.
So it gets cold
before people come.
Zündhölzer? Hat es.
Wir müssen schauen,
ob sie auch voll sind.
Ich bin in einem der Ferienhäuser,
aber gleich bei Ihnen.
Bye-bye!
Das war eine junge Frau, die hier
auf dem Gelände heiraten möchte.
Wir werden sie nun treffen,
ihre Fragen beantworten
und ihr die Anlage zeigen, damit sie
sich ein Bild davon machen kann.
Okay, we go?
Okay.
Jules überlässt es Janette, die
Besucherin übers Gelände zu führen.
Er sieht sich eher
als Mann im Hintergrund,
der sich um die Finanzen kümmert.
Die Rolle der Gastgeberin
ist für Frau Miriam vorgesehen,
sobald sie hier ist.
Am Abend telefoniert Jules
mit dem Verkäufer der Liegenschaft.
2,4 Mio. Fr.
müssen Landolts aufbringen.
Ein grosser Teil davon
fehlt immer noch.
Und die Zahlungsfrist läuft bald ab.
Es sieht gut aus,
sogar sehr gut.
Wir tun unser Bestes, um den Termin
für die Zahlung zu halten.
Für Sie wäre es besser, wenn wir
so schnell wie möglich bezahlen.
Jules setzt darauf,
Investoren in der Schweiz zu finden.
Als Finanzspezialist
hat er ein gutes Netzwerk.
Aber bis jetzt
hat er nur vage Zusagen.
Bye, Bill, bye!
Die australischen Zinsen
sind einfach doppelt so hoch
wie Schweizer Zinsen,
und wir würden gerne
aus der Schweiz heraus finanzieren.
Die australischen Investoren
wollen einen für ihre Verhältnisse
normalen Zins, und der fängt bei
7-8 % an. Das ist für uns abstrus.
Zwei Wochen später
heisst es Abschied nehmen.
Vater Jules muss zurück nach Glarus.
Er verlässt seine Kinder, noch bevor
Mutter Miriam hier eintrifft.
Jules hat seinen Job behalten.
Der Traum vom Auswandern bedeutet
für ihn über 10'000 km pendeln.
Für mich
wird es wahrscheinlich hart sein,
ein paar Monate
ohne Kinder zu sein.
Aber solange ich den Job habe,
gibt es eine finanzielle Sicherheit.
Das bedeutet für mich im Moment
weniger Stress,
als wenn ich voll Risiko alles auf-
gebe und das Zweiteinkommen fehlt.
Bis Mutter Miriam endlich kommt,
schaut Janette nach den Kindern.
Here comes your Mum, here comes
your Mum, here comes your Mum.
Wiedersehensfreude bei Tochter Mirja.
Ihre Mutter
ist in Coffs Harbour angekommen.
Miriam kann nun endlich wieder
für ihre Kinder da sein.
Aber: Es wartet auch
viel Arbeit auf sie im Ferienresort.
Am anderen Ende der Welt stürzt sich
Vater Jules in die Arbeit.
Er ist Finanzchef in der Schweiz,
bei einem international
tätigen Unternehmen.
Ich habe jetzt zehn Jahre lang
auch so etwas
wie einen Traum gelebt.
Und sie hat zurückgesteckt
und gesagt,
jetzt wäre es für sie auch ...
Wieso nicht auch mal sie?
Mit der Familie,
und weil alle so Feuer und Flamme
für das Projekt sind,
finde ich,
wenn ich es einrichten kann,
trete ich einen Schritt zurück
und stelle mich
in den Dienst der Familie.
Die Finanzierung des Ferienresort
ist ein ungelöstes Problem,
um das sich Jules
dringend kümmern muss.
Auf Friday Creek
hat sich eine Hochzeitsgesellschaft
mit 80 Gästen eingemietet.
Wir dekorieren noch fertig und
dann brechen wir wahrscheinlich auf.
Um 16.00 Uhr kommen wir wieder.
Bis dahin bin ich zurück.
- Dann machen wir eine Probe.
Melde dich, wenn du etwas brauchst.
Bye-bye.
Ab sofort ist Miriam
Hotelmanagerin, Zimmermädchen
und Hausmeisterin in einem.
Nur eine Putzfrau
und ein Gärtner helfen ihr.
Miriam und ihre Familie sind dringend
auf Einnahmen angewiesen.
Solange das Resort
nicht vollständig bezahlt ist,
haben sie es nur gepachtet.
Monat für Monat müssen sie
rund 12'000 Fr. aufbringen.
Spinnencheck!
Für bis zu 280 Fr.,
welche Gäste pro Nacht bezahlen,
wollen sie ein Zimmer
ohne Ungeziefer.
Und tatsächlich:
Miriam hat eine Spinne entdeckt.
Eklig, schau! Uah!
In Glarus schleppt Ehemann Jules
die letzten persönlichen Gegenstände
aus dem ehemaligen Wohnhaus
der Familie.
Um Geld zu sparen,
wollen Landolts es vermieten.
Bereits zweimal stand Jules
mit australischen Banken
kurz vor dem Abschluss.
Aber diesen
war das Projekt zu unsicher
und sie haben auch
seinen Job in der Schweiz
nicht als Sicherheit akzeptiert.
Zurzeit ist es so,
dass ich hier die Unterstützung
leiste, die wir dort brauchen.
Es ist einfach nicht gerade toll,
wenn du hier in der Schweiz bist,
so weit entfernt von deiner Familie.
Das macht einen natürlich
schon nicht an.
Dann ...
Verfluchen würde ich
nicht gerade sagen,
aber man hinterfragt
das ganze Modell schon wieder.
Jules kommt bis auf Weiteres
bei Freunden unter.
* Aborigines-Gesang *
Exotische Klänge auf Friday Creek.
Miriam Landolt
hat für Schweizer Gäste
ein kulturelles Programm organisiert.
Das "Welcome to Country"
ist eine traditionelle Zeremonie
der Aborigines.
This is a part of the welcome.
The welcome to country,
the welcome to Gumbangyrr Country.
Das Programm für die Gäste
hat Miriam gemeinsam
mit den Ureinwohnern entwickelt.
Sie benutzen das Feuer,
also der männliche Teil,
daher macht das Onkel Martin,
um euch zu reinigen.
Das ist sehr heilend.
Wir haben jetzt sehr schnell
die Cultural Programms ausgebaut.
Die Leute lieben es.
Es ist etwas sehr Spezielles.
Die Leute fühlen sich sehr berührt
und das ist eigentlich
das grosse Ziel dieses Resorts.
Dass man möglichst viele Gäste ein-
lädt, die diese Programme mitmachen.
Das wird jetzt auch
sehr schnell hinausgetragen,
dass das etwas sehr Spezielles ist.
Die Ferienanlage läuft unter Miriams
Führung immer besser.
Lichtblicke
gibt es auch bei den Finanzen:
Ein australischer Investor
interessiert sich
für Jules neues Konzept.
Zusätzlich zum Ferienresort möchte
Jules Landwirtschaft betreiben,
Aborigines anstellen
und Teebaumöl produzieren.
Landolts läuft aber die Zeit davon.
In einer Stunde
kommt Verkäufer Bill.
Er will endlich sein Geld.
Der jüngste der Familie hat bereits
sein Sparschwein geplündert.
Jannis hat mir schon Mal
200 Fr. gegeben. Nicht wahr?
Ja.
- Wofür?
Dafür!
- Ja, genau.
Da hat er mir
einen Zettel geschrieben:
"Von Jannis für Friday Creek."
Und zwei 100er-Noten gegeben.
- Ja, genau.
Super!
Trotz neuem Konzept
und dem interessierten Investor
möchte Verkäufer Bill
keinen Aufschub mehr gewähren.
Im letzten Jahr
hatten wir zwei, drei gute Anläufe
und es hat dann
im letzten Moment nicht geklappt.
Jetzt sind wir eigentlich
wieder am gleichen Punkt.
Wie damals
sieht es sehr gut aus.
Ich denke, er glaubt
jetzt einfach nicht daran.
Jules und Miriam sind sich aber
sicher, dass es dieses Mal klappt.
Die Partner,
die wir jetzt haben,
sind zehn bis 20 Jahre
bei uns dabei.
Das ist anders als eine Bank,
die schnell eine Hypothek spricht.
Das ist
eine sehr bekannte Institution.
Dann macht es wusch und du hast
ganz viele andere Tore offen
für mögliche andere Co-Partner
für die nächsten Jahre.
Alles hängt nun davon ab,
ob sie es schaffen,
Verkäufer Bill von ihrem Konzept,
das Geld bringen soll, zu überzeugen.
Sie haben den Vertrag gekündigt.
Ja, er ist abgelaufen.
Nehmen wir an, ich verlängere
den Vertrag um 14 Tage
und diese Investoren
geben Ihnen trotzdem nicht das Geld.
Was wird dann am 15. geschehen?
Bill, wir sind ganz sicher,
dass wir die Risikoprüfung des
australischen Investors bestehen.
Innerhalb der Frist, bis zum 15.?
Ja, bis dahin werden Sie
etwas in der Hand haben.
Sie sind sehr optimistisch,
Miriam.
Sie haben in den letzten zwei Jahren
nichts zustande bekommen.
Das ist ihre Perspektive.
Wir haben bisher
alle unsere Ziele erreicht.
Das einzige, was nicht funktio-
nierte, ist der Kreditvertrag,
weil die Bank kurz vor Abschluss
ihre Zusage zurückzog.
Sie müssen doch zugeben,
dass Ihre Art und Weise,
wie Sie Geldgeber für das Resort
suchen, sehr ungewöhnlich ist.
Niemand macht das so!
Ich verstehe Ihre Zweifel.
Aber wir haben eine grössere Vision,
als nur dieses Resort zu betreiben.
Wir wollen mit den Ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten.
Und dafür braucht es
unorthodoxe Wege.
Und wir haben nun
einen solchen gefunden.
Das ist jetzt der beste Weg,
die beste Möglichkeit.
Fakt ist, Sie hätten bereits
am 1. Oktober ausziehen müssen.
Wir geben Ihnen
noch einmal zwei Wochen.
Einen weiteren Aufschub werden wir
Ihnen auf keinen Fall mehr gewähren.
Dessen müssen Sie sich bewusst sein.
Okay.
Alright.
Bye!
Sagt Bill tschüss!
Zwei Wochen später: Auf Friday Creek
ist die Zeit für Landolts abgelaufen.
Heute ist der Tag, an dem sie
ihre Sachen packen müssten.
Und die Zusage des Investors
steht immer noch aus.
Aber die Familie
hält an ihrem Traum fest.
Noch mal!
Nicht?
Super!
Dann: unvermittelt eine Nachricht
auf Miriams Mobiltelefon.
Wir sind weiter im Due-Diligence.
Cool.
Landolts haben die Risikoprüfung
tatsächlich bestanden.
Die Familie bekommt das Geld
vom australischen Investor.
Ja, da ist er.
Das schicke ich jetzt Bills Anwalt.
Ja!
Die Finanzierung von Friday Creek
schien gesichert.
Doch die Geschichte von Familie
Landolt nahm eine andere Wendung.
Wir hatten grundsätzlich
die Finanzierungszusage.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatten wir aber
die Konditionen und die Bedingungen
nicht im Detail.
Die haben wir später bekommen.
Wir haben sie studiert,
ausgelotet, geprüft
und uns gefragt,
worauf wir uns genau verlassen.
Es war eine mittel-
bis langfristige Finanzierung.
Und dann mussten wir sagen:
Das ist ein Korsett,
mit dem du nicht mehr atmen kannst.
Und ich musste sagen:
Rein aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen
können und dürfen wir das
nicht eingehen.
Das war keine einfache Entscheidung.
Wir hätten sie eigentlich gehabt,
aber was bringt es uns,
wenn ich dann nicht mehr atmen
und mit der Familie dort leben kann?
Das wollte ich nicht.
Trotz aller Bemühungen konnte Jules
keine Investoren mehr finden.
Und Bill wollte sich auf einen weite-
ren Pachtvertrag nicht einlassen.
Er klagte beim Obersten Gericht
von New South Wales
auf Rückgabe des Grundstückes.
Kurz vor dem Gerichtstermin
einigten sich beide Parteien
auf einen Vergleich,
der Landolts weitere zwei Monate
zur Zahlung einräumte.
Als die Familie auch diesen Termin
nicht einhalten konnte,
kam der Fall vor den Richter.
Wir hatten
Meinungsverschiedenheiten,
auch gewisse Interessenskonflikte
mit ihm,
aber ich denke,
das gehört zur Natur des Geschäfts,
dass man nicht immer
gleicher Meinung ist.
Wir haben für unsere Sache gekämpft,
er hat für sein Recht gekämpft.
Wir haben Steuern und Versicherungen
für das ganze Resort bezahlt.
Wir haben Investitionen
in die Infrastruktur bezahlt,
das ganze Marketing aufgebaut.
Das haben wir aus eigenen Erspar-
nissen, mit unserem Geld bezahlt.
Und wir wollten,
dass uns das angerechnet würde.
Das Gericht bestätigte den Vergleich.
Das Eigentum des Anwesens
ging an Verkäufer Bill zurück.
Familie Landolt musste Friday Creek
im Juli 2015 verlassen.
Danach stellten beide Parteien
gegenseitige Forderungen.
Mittlerweile konnten sie sich aber
aussergerichtlich einigen.
Während der Mittagszeit
ist es ruhig in der Bar.
Bei frühsommerlichen Temperaturen
tummeln sich die Touristen am Strand.
Marcel nutzt die freie Zeit
für einen Einkauf.
Hello!
Hey!
Im britischen Supermarkt
ist er Stammkunde.
Zwei Packungen Guinness.
Falls diese nicht reichen,
hole ich morgen noch einmal zwei.
Ja, sicher.
- Bye-bye.
Marcel fühlt sich in Griechenland
sehr wohl.
Sein alter Job als Vertreter
ist für ihn abgehakt.
Für mich ist die Schweiz erledigt.
Das ist höchstens noch
ein Ferienziel für mich.
Ich bin jetzt in Kreta zu Hause
und nirgendwo anders.
Ich habe auch kein Heimweh.
Ich habe mich so an das schöne
Wetter gewöhnt, an meinen neuen Job,
an die Selbstständigkeit
und dass ich mehr oder weniger
machen kann, was ich will.
Aber arbeiten muss man überall.
Als Chef seiner Bar geniesst er
die neue Freiheit in vollen Zügen.
Auch Ehefrau Trix
strotzt vor Tatendrang.
Im neuen Zuhause
trifft sie letzte Vorbereitungen.
Sie hat ihr eigenes
Bed & Breakfast eröffnet.
Das ist jetzt unser Studio,
das wir vermieten.
Und jetzt bekommen wir Gäste,
die drei Wochen lang bleiben.
In der Schweiz
hat Trix Schuhe verkauft.
Auf Kreta sorgt sie dafür,
dass für ihre zahlenden Besucher
alles passt.
So, die ist startklar.
Die Leute können kommen.
Für mich ist es wichtig,
dass ich auch etwas zu tun habe.
Ich habe in der Schweiz
das Leben lang gearbeitet.
Und nachher hast du plötzlich
keine Aufgabe mehr.
Was für mich das Schlimmste war:
In der Schweiz
hatte ich mein eigenes Konto
und hier muss ich immer fragen.
Jetzt mache ich
mein eigenes Geschäft,
ich bekomme regelmässig Trinkgeld,
und so habe ich
auch für mich selber etwas.
Ich muss jetzt nicht immer fragen.
Da sehe ich,
dass ich nicht gut gewischt habe.
Da muss ich noch einmal darüber.
Das Studio ist bereit.
Gleich muss Trix los zum Flughafen.
Ihre Gäste landen in 2 Std.
Das Heimweh war zu gross.
Nicole Gerstner und Sohn Joshua sind
für zwei Wochen in Thun zu Besuch.
Sie wollen Heimatluft schnuppern,
Verwandte und Freunde treffen.
Wunderschön!
Und: Nicole
möchte sich in der Schweiz
über Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten
für Sohn Joshua informieren.
Mit seinen 15 Jahren
steht die Berufswahl an.
Ich habe gedacht,
etwas Handwerkliches:
Zimmermann, Holzbau, so etwas.
Aber ich versteife mich
noch nicht zu fest auf etwas.
Ich bin noch offen.
Ja, das gibt es dort natürlich
nicht, eine Berufslehre.
Man geht auf die High School,
ins College und dann studieren.
Studieren müsste er auf San Jose.
Das wäre nicht das Ziel,
das möchten wir alle nicht.
Dann lieber zurück in die Schweiz,
hier eine Lehre machen.
Das wäre ein Grund, zurückzukommen,
um ihn zu besuchen.
Tschüss zusammen!
Nach dem Frühstück geht's los
zum Berufsinformationszentrum.
Gehen wir nach vorne und dann ...
- Gut.
Ja, gehen wir hier vorne durch.
Gut?
- Ja.
Guten Morgen, Gerstner, freut mich.
- Hallo, Joshua.
Guten Tag.
Wir gehen gleich rein.
- Gut.
Den Termin bei Berufsberaterin
Bettina Winkler
hat Nicole
von Costa Rica aus organisiert.
Also, das hat ja gut geklappt.
- Ja.
Wir sind einigermassen pünktlich.
Den Hut kannst du abziehen.
Ja ich muss zuerst wissen,
wie es in Costa Rica läuft -
auch schulmässig.
Vielleicht kannst du mir sagen,
welche Fächer du in der Schule hast.
Vom Schulmaterial her
ist es ein wenig einfacher als hier.
Aber von der Sprache her
ist es schwierig.
Ja. Und Sprachen?
Worauf beziehst du dich jetzt?
Auf Englisch und Spanisch.
- Auf beide. Du hast beide Sprachen.
Aber: Für eine Lehre in der Schweiz
sind eher Deutsch und Französisch
gefragt.
Das ist die Schwierigkeit,
die wir im Moment haben:
Wie kompatibel ist das Ganze?
Was wird dort verlangt,
sofern du zurückkommst?
Das sind so die schwierigen Fragen.
Das ist schon spezieller als sonst?
- Ja, genau.
Das er eventuell aufholen müsste.
Wenn Joshua Pech hat,
muss er die Abschlussklasse
in der Schweiz wiederholen.
* Gemächliche Musik *
In Costa Rica,
rund 9'000 km entfernt,
beginnt für Mike der Arbeitstag.
Sein Projekt für heute: Bäume fällen.
Ein Knochenjob
bei über 30 °C im Schatten.
Die Bäume verdecken den Pool
von einem der beiden neuen Häuser,
die auf ihrem Grundstück
gebaut werden.
Doch als Erstes
muss die Stromversorgung weg.
Das ist Tico-Style,
das läuft ein wenig anders
als bei uns in der Schweiz.
Nein, nein. Das ist safe!
Diese Gelassenheit
hat Mike erst lernen müssen.
Was die Zukunft
von Sohn Joshua angeht,
ist er jedoch nicht so entspannt.
Eine gute Ausbildung wie in der
Schweiz bekommst du nicht überall.
Sie ist nach wie vor hoch angesehen.
Ich finde, wenn er eine gute
Lehrstelle findet und eine Idee hat,
was er lernen möchte, finde ich das
begrüssenswert, wenn er das macht.
Das sind zwei bis drei Jahre,
vielleicht vier Jahre,
und danach steht ihm die Welt offen.
Er kann machen was er will.
Mit seiner Mehrsprachigkeit und
all dem, was er sonst noch macht,
ist er ziemlich flexibel
für die Zukunft.
Sohn Joaquin
ist zurück vom Dorfladen.
Er hat das Znüni besorgt.
Super.
Ich habe auch
ein paar Raffaellos gekauft. -
Raffaellos hast du auch gekauft?
Du mästest mich.
Gutschweizerische Tugenden und
lateinamerikanische Lebensfreude:
Für seine Kinder wünscht sich Mike
das Beste aus zwei Welten.
An der Ostküste beginnt der Frühling.
Nach zwei Monaten in der Schweiz
ist Jules für einige Tage
bei seiner Familie.
Ein weiteres Mal nur zu Besuch.
Good!
We are on the way to school now.
Ich fühle mich ziemlich wohl hier,
das muss ich sagen.
Meine Heimat bleibt wahrscheinlich
immer die Schweiz,
dafür bin ich wohl schon zu alt,
dass ich sagen kann,
es gibt eine zweite Heimat.
Aber ich finde es ein tolles Land,
wir haben viele Möglichkeiten.
Und ja ... es gefällt mir gut hier.
Landolts bringen ihre Kinder
zusammen zur Schule.
Wenn Jules da ist, kostet die Familie
jede Sekunde gemeinsam aus.
Hopp, hopp.
Tschüss.
Tschüss, Mama.
Der klemmt.
Tschüss, Papi.
- Tschüss. Mach's gut.
Julian, hast du den Hut?
Gut. Tschüss.
Im Gegensatz zu ihrem Vater
sind die Kinder längst
in Australien angekommen.
Mirja geht bereits
in die High School,
Jelena, Jannis und Julian
in die Steiner Schule.
* Verspielte Musik *
* Schräge Flötenklänge *
Zurück im Ferienhaus machen sich
Jules und Miriam an die Arbeit.
Sie nutzen die kinderfreie Zeit
und prüfen Angebote
für verschiedene Resorts.
Siehst du, da draussen
hat es mehrere Tischchen.
Da haben einen Whirlpool,
eine Badewanne inside.
Das ist das Bad.
Dann das Schlafzimmer.
Es ist schon old style,
aber schau mal,
das sind Steinmauern.
Der Unterschied ...
Die Bauweise ist wie bei uns.
Ein 100-jähriges Haus
ist qualitativ extrem gut gebaut.
Das sind nicht
so Kartonhäuschen wie dieses.
Es hat aber hässliche Teppiche.
- Die nehmen wir raus.
Im Gegensatz zu Friday Creek
ist diese Anlage viel kleiner.
Mit vier Cabines kannst du das
eigentlich ohne Personal handeln.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Mit neun Cabines
und 100 Acres Umschwung
bist du nonstop beschäftigt.
Entweder hast du Angestellte
oder du bist nonstop beschäftigt.
Dreiviertel vom Jahr das Gras mähen,
die Gartenpflege usw.
Das ist ein Riesenaufwand.
Wenn du diese Arbeitskraftkosten
nicht hast,
kannst du mit der Hälfte der Cabins
fast gleich viel Umsatz machen.
Morgen wollen sie
die Liegenschaft besichtigen.
Marcel ist heute
früher als sonst in der Bar.
Er möchte mehr Leute
auf The Zep aufmerksam machen.
Das Problem: Die Touristen
kommen nur in der Saison
zwischen Mai und Oktober.
Die Pacht für das Lokal aber
muss er auch im Winter bezahlen,
wenn die Bar geschlossen ist.
Im Moment sieht es gut aus.
Letztes Jahr konnten wir
in ein paar Monaten alles zahlen -
also Angestellte, die Miete
für die Bar und für das Haus ...
Dieses Jahr ist es sehr gut
angelaufen, und ich verspreche mir,
dass es für den Winter reicht -
auch mit Studio,
das wir vermieten können.
Das hilft natürlich auch.
Wenn wir den Sommer durch
unsere Franken machen können,
reicht das schon.
Ich möchte ja nicht
Millionär werden.
Ich möchte einfach
ein schönes, gutes Leben haben.
Und v.a. ...
... die Zeit zwischendurch
auch noch geniessen.
So ...
Ich halte die Schablone
und du streichst.
Wir brauchen eine Stelle, die
eben ist. Diese hier ist nicht gut.
We want it flat.
Vielleicht hier?
Probieren wir es hier!
Drück sie fest ran!
Barman Nikos assistiert.
Das Logo auf der Treppe
soll ein Blickfang sein
und Touristen anlocken.
Das war zu viel Farbe.
Wir können immer noch ...
schwarz drüber.
Dann haben wir einfach
einen schwarzen Block da.
Dann haben wir es wieder gerettet.
Das ist nicht gut.
Vielleicht sollten wir es
mit einer Spraydose probieren.
Aber dann wird alles schwarz.
Eine Dose sprüht so.
It's better.
- Better.
Es ist besser, ja.
Das ist okay so.
Wir machen da noch eins hin
und vielleicht hier,
aber keine 20.
The Zep soll auffallen.
Die Konkurrenz in Agios Nikolaos
ist gross.
Okay, vamos.
Dann bis morgen. Tschüss, Papa!
Ciao Richi, gracias. Hasta mañana.
Ciao, ciao.
(Mann) Ciao, hasta mañana.
Nicole ist wieder zu Hause.
Nach zwei Wochen in der alten Heimat
hat sie der Familienalltag wieder.
Sie holt Betty ab.
Das italienische Mädchen ist eine
Schulfreundin von Tochter Joseline.
Der neue Bekanntenkreis der Thuner
ist bunt gemischt.
Aber er besteht
fast ausnahmslos aus Menschen,
die wie sie
nach Costa Rica ausgewandert sind.
Es hat so viele
verschiedene Nationalitäten.
Wir haben fast am wenigsten
mit ...
... mit Ticos zu tun.
Es ist eigentlich schlimm,
das zu sagen.
Aber hier sind Leute aus der
ganzen Welt zusammengewürfelt.
Mir gefällt das sehr.
Es funktioniert auch gut.
Aber es ist schon nicht
ein typischer ...
Es ist nicht
das typische Costa Rica hier.
Die Familie lebt in einer Welt,
zu der v.a. Leute mit Geld
Zutritt haben.
Achtung, fertig ...
Tochter Joseline hat mittlerweile
Freundinnen gefunden,
aber es hat länger gedauert
als gedacht.
Anfangs konnte sie sich
in Costa Rica kaum verständigen.
Die Kinder
sind mehr als angekommen.
Die sind definitiv daheim.
Sie haben Freunde gefunden und haben
ihr soziales Umfeld etabliert.
Sie sprechen nach so kurzer Zeit
fliessend Spanisch und Englisch.
Ja, die gehen auf, sie haben Spass,
die geniessen es extrem.
Das ist schön zu sehen.
Darf ich eins von denen nehmen?
Die sind nicht für euch, Schatzis.
- Für wen dann?
No es para Ustedes. Solo para mi ...
... y Michael.
Die Sorgen, die Mike und Nicole
wegen ihrer Kinder hatten,
haben sich in Luft aufgelöst.
Die beiden wirken zufrieden
in der neuen Heimat.
Geht's? Sitzt du bequem?
- Super bequem.
Down Under lassen sich Jules und
Miriam viel Zeit für den Neuanfang.
Das nächste Resort,
das wir anschauen, läuft schon.
Wir fangen nicht bei Null an.
Es hat eine sehr hohe Auslastung
und wir müssen marketingmässig
nicht alles selber machen.
Man lebt vom Tourismusstrom
an und für sich.
Das ist ein grosser Teil,
der Umsatz bringt,
und man hat natürlich
viel weniger Druck.
Ein weiterer Vorteil: Die
Liegenschaft ist eine Nummer kleiner.
Die Ferienanlage befindet sich
am Rand eines kleinen Dorfes.
Hier treffen Landolts Uncle Martin,
einen Stammesältesten.
Vier Gästehäuser liegen gut versteckt
inmitten eines tropischen Gartens.
Gefällt es dir hier?
Es ist sehr schön,
ein kleines Paradies.
So heisst es im Slogan.
Mit den Aborigines
vom Stamm der Gumbaynggir
ist Miriam schon seit über 20 Jahren
eng verbunden.
Uncle Martin soll prüfen,
ob dies der richtige Ort
für einen Neuanfang sein könnte.
Wow, beautiful!
Das Land ist den Aborigines heilig.
Sie begegnen allem Geschaffenen
mit tiefen Respekt.
Ich setzte mich mal hier hin
und höre, was die Steine sagen.
Die Energie ist wirklich gut.
Das ist eine Quelle.
Ich werde mich in sie hineinstellen.
Das Wasser kommt hier aus der Erde.
Es ist gut.
Die Meinung von Uncle Martin
ist Landolts besonders wichtig.
Ohne sein Okay werden sie
auf keinen Fall hierherziehen.
Es ist sehr schön hier,
und es fühlt sich gut an.
Es ist alles vorhanden:
Wasser, Steine und der Feigenbaum.
Eine gute Mischung
aller Schwingungen.
Für Uncle Martin
stimmen die Energien.
Doch Landolts wollen sich momentan
noch nicht auf ein Resort festlegen.
Gegenwärtig prüfen sie,
in welcher Form sie ein solches
finanzieren und übernehmen könnten.
Ob als Pächter,
Eigentümer oder Manager.
Trix kommt zurück
vom Flughafen in Heraklion.
Sie hat ihre ersten Gäste
aus der Schweiz abgeholt.
So, Anita.
Da ist deine Jacke.
Magst du das gerade nehmen?
Ja genau.
Seid so gut.
Perfekter Service:
Trix ist in ihrem Element.
Sollen wir die Koffer
gleich mit reinnehmen?
(Mann) Man könnte meinen,
wir bleiben für ein Jahr.
Immerhin seid ihr
drei Wochen bei mir.
So.
Das ist eine Art Garderobe,
wo du das hinhängen könntest.
Ich zeige es dir.
Also schlaft gut, bis morgen früh.
- Bis morgen, nicht zu früh.
Nein das mache ich nicht.
Gästezimmer vermieten: Trix
hat eine erfüllende Aufgabe gefunden.
Und eine zusätzliche Einnahmequelle.
Für Ehemann Marcel
beginnt die Arbeit in der Bar.
Guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren,
willkommen im Zep.
Heute Abend
haben wir Livemusic von Jannis,
einem der bekanntesten
Alleinunterhalter auf Kreta,
vielleicht sogar ganz Griechenlands.
* Stimmungsvolle Musik *
Die Gäste kommen.
The Zep läuft immer besser.
Während der Hochsaison
hat Marcel sogar vier Angestellte.
Die Abendschicht
übernimmt der Chef immer persönlich.
* Applaus *
Es ist sicher ein gewisser Stolz da,
weil ich etwas geschaffen habe,
wovon viele andere nur reden.
Eben: Lebe deinen Traum,
träume nicht dein Leben!
Wir sind jetzt
auf einem guten Weg dazu.
8 Uhr am nächsten Morgen.
Trix ist schon seit Längerem
auf den Beinen
und bereitet das Frühstück vor.
Jetzt geht es los.
Meine Gäste sind hungrig.
Ehemann Marcel schläft noch.
Er ist erst um 4 Uhr
aus der Bar nach Hause gekommen.
Wir sind ja noch keine Rentner.
Wir sind hierhergekommen,
um hier zu arbeiten.
Und da ich nicht
mit Marcel zusammenarbeiten kann,
hat jetzt jeder sein Ding.
Guten Morgen zusammen.
- Guten Morgen, Trix.
Habt ihr gut geschlafen.
- Oh, ja.
Wunderbar.
Nicht so lange, aber sehr gut.
Dein Orangesaft. Du hast mir gesagt,
du wolltest keinen, Anita.
Trix und Marcel haben ihren Platz
im griechischen Alltag gefunden.
Auch Mike und Nicole kommen
ihrem Ziel Stück für Stück näher.
Gleich zwei neue Häuser
entstehen auf ihrem Grundstück.
Eins davon soll ihr Traumhaus werden.
Für den Bau haben die Auswanderer
Architekt Ghadi beauftragt.
Buenas.
Für Mike und Nicole drängt die Zeit.
In drei Monaten
muss die Villa sie fertig sein.
Ihr altes Haus haben sie bereits
an Touristen vermietet.
Sie investieren viel Geld.
Da muss jedes Detail perfekt sein.
Es sieht dann schon kleiner aus.
Es ist so klein geworden,
unglaublich.
It looks small!
Bis hierher geht das Bett, 2 m.
Das gibt das Schlafzimmer.
Sie findet es etwas klein.
2,20 minus 40, das ist gross!
It's huge, it's all good.
- Was haben wir denn hier?
Und schon das nächste Problem:
Die Dusche ist zu schmal.
Wir können die Dusche
bis hierhin machen,
aber dann muss man das Holz
mit Kunststoff überziehen.
Oder wir verbreitern die Mauer
um 30 cm
und setzen den Holzpfeiler darüber.
- Das wäre auch eine Möglichkeit.
Und wo ist es dann offen?
- Hier hast du einen Pfosten.
Sorry, Ghadi.
Hier hast du weitere 30 cm.
Hier kommt Bamboo, dann
der Pfosten und dann alles Bamboo.
Man entscheidet sehr viel
noch auf der Baustelle.
Was in der Schweiz
schon im Vorfeld ganz klar ist,
kannst du hier noch relativ spontan,
während des Baus machen.
So manches lässt sich
ganz unbürokratisch lösen.
Es ist einfacher als in der Schweiz.
Ich glaube, für dieses Haus haben
wir noch gar keine Bewilligung.
Oder?
Du kannst mit der Fantasie spielen,
ausprobieren ...
Du kannst eigentlich machen,
was du willst.
Mike und Nicole
könnten es eigentlich ruhig angehen.
Und wieder einmal
nehmen sie sich vor,
endlich mehr costa-ricanische
Gelassenheit zu leben.
Im Moment bauen wir,
und wenn wir fertig sind,
träumen wir weiter.
Dann geniessen wir es mal.
Jetzt haben wir fast zwei Jahre lang
nur gebaut.
Wir wollen mal noch das pura vida,
von dem man hier immer spricht.
Das ist noch ein wenig
zu kurz gekommen.
Ganz langsam laufen,
sonst gehen sie weg.
Familienausflug ins Naturreservat.
Vater Jules muss in zwei Tagen
schon wieder zurück in die Schweiz.
Schau, das ist ein grosser. Uncle
Bill würde ihn grandfather nennen.
Welcher? Der dort, der davon ist?
- Nein, der hier.
Er hat die Verteidigungsstellung
eingenommen.
Ja.
Wusstet ihr, dass Kängurus
nicht rückwärts laufen können?
* Leidenschaftliche Musik *
Leben und arbeiten -
zusammen mit den Aborigines.
Mit dieser Vision hat
für Familie Landolt alles begonnen.
Voller Zuversicht sind sie
nach Australien ausgewandert.
Mehr als zwei Jahre lang
haben sie gekämpft.
Nun müssen Jules und seine Familie
von vorne beginnen.
Ein Wal. Ein Wal, schau!
Dort, wow!
Hast du ihn gesehen, Jannis?
Dort, schau, schau, schau!
* Jubelrufe *
Jules ist auch weiterhin
nur zu Besuch hier.
Aber die Familie
hält an ihrem Traum fest.
Die letzten zwei, drei Jahre
haben mir wieder einen ganz anderen
Antrieb gegeben im Leben.
Du bist so in einer Komfortzone drin,
bewegst dich natürlich sehr gut
in der Komfortzone.
Einfach, gemütlich,
du hast alles im Leben.
Und wenn du das mal loslässt, ent-
deckst du neue Sachen, neue Freunde.
Die Welt ist gross
und bietet wirklich tolle Sachen.
Das neue Leben in Australien
bleibt für Familie Landolt
ein grosses Abenteuer
mit offenem Ausgang.
Ein paarmal pro Woche holt Trix
ihren Marcel zum Abendessen ab.
Bist du so weit, Hase?
- Ich komme.
Ich bringe das noch kurz rein.
Hast du gesehen? Unsere Schablone?
- Ja, das ist schön.
Es sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Wir machen dort noch eines und dort,
und dann ist fertig.
Ja, ja. Also komm,
wir gehen auf die andere Seite.
Warte,
sonst wirst du noch überfahren.
Wenn schon nach dem Essen.
Wir müssen erst noch
das Essen geniessen.
Warte, ich muss noch was versorgen.
- Was kramst du wieder rum?
Ein Leben am Meer
in der Wärme des Südens,
eine Rock- und Bluesbar
und das eigene B&B.
Marcel und Trix haben das gemacht,
wovon viele träumen.
Sie haben den Lauf des Lebens
nicht dem Schicksal überlassen,
sondern es mutig
in die eigenen Hände genommen.
Thank you, sir.
Guten Appetit, Hase.
- Ja, gleichfalls.
Es ist eigentlich alles
in Erfüllung gegangen,
wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben.
Und es passt beiden zu 100 %.
Was wollen wir eigentlich mehr?
Das ist das Wichtigste,
dass es beiden passt.
Als sie mich fragte,
wann ich auswandern wolle,
war für mich der Fall schon klar.
Du musst eigentlich nur noch
den Ball ins Rollen bringen.
Wir haben
den ersten Anstoss gegeben.
Und jetzt müssen wir einfach
den Wagen am Laufen behalten.
Ich muss noch arbeiten.
Mike, Nicole und die Kinder
sind unterwegs zum Strand.
Zum ersten Mal ist auch Mariana
mit dabei, Joshuas neue Freundin.
Good for me.
Vor zwei Jahren ist Mike mit seiner
Familie nach Costa Rica gezogen.
Der Schritt scheint sich auch für sie
gelohnt zu haben.
29 °C warmes Wasser,
Sommer das ganze Jahr hindurch
und die Freiheit, tun und lassen
zu können, was man möchte.
* Gemächliche
lateinamerikanische Musik *
Die Playa Santa Teresa
ist für die Familie
zum zweiten Wohnzimmer geworden.
Manches haben sie sich zu Beginn
einfacher vorgestellt.
Aber sie bereuen es nicht,
Thun verlassen zu haben.
Ich geniesse es jetzt auch
schon mehr als am Anfang.
Am Anfang haben wir alles
reingesteckt. Ich zumindest.
Das mussten wir auch.
Wir hatten unsere Welt,
wo alles stimmte in der Schweiz.
Es war alles gut, alles
hat funktioniert, ist lief.
Manchmal bin ich selber
darüber überrascht,
dass wir es gemacht haben.
Wir hatten keine Ahnung,
was passiert.
Ich glaube, es sind zwei Sachen:
Wir hatten Glück, aber wir mussten
uns das Glück auch erarbeiten.
Seither ist es gut,
es funktioniert bis jetzt.
Das alte Leben hinter sich lassen,
Neues wagen,
wie Pioniere die Welt erobern.
So wandern jedes Jahr viele
Schweizerinnen und Schweizern aus
und suchen ihr Glück in der Ferne.
Und auch wir
begleiten wieder einige von ihnen.
Ich müsste mich abmelden.
- Klar. Wohin geht es?
Nach Deutschland!
- Okay, gleich ins Ausland.
Nur im Ausland findet er Platz
für seine vier sibirischen Tiger -
und für seinen Traum:
In der Schweiz
ist ein solcher Park unmöglich.
Jeh!
Alexandra Taetz und Remo Müller
wollen ihren eigenen Tierpark bauen.
Aber nur langsam
fassen Remos Wildkatzen
Vertrauen in ihr neues Daheim.
* Fauchen *
Nein, nein.
Auch die Bauarbeiten
sind kurz vor der Eröffnung
noch immer nicht abgeschlossen.
Und dann fegt noch ein heftiger Sturm
über den Park.
Es soll ja noch mehr Sturm kommen.
Die Ostschweizer Familie Ruckstuhl
wandert nach Kanada aus -
zum zweiten Mal.
Der erste Versuch scheiterte jäh.
Tochter Josephine wurde schwer krank
und die Familie musste die neue
Heimat erst einmal wieder verlassen.
Jetzt hat Vater Markus
eine Anstellung als Farmarbeiter
und wird zum Cowboy.
Ja, Technik.
Ein Schlaufe.
Kälbchen aufpäppeln gehört für
die Familie schon bald zur Routine.
Mal schauen,
ob er das überhaupt überlebt.
Aber wie entwickelt sich
die kleine Josephine
in der neuen Heimat?
Und auf und davon
in den Süden Spaniens.
Auf einem Pferdegestüt mit Reitschule
wollen Myriam Thomann und Urs Batzli
endlich ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
führen.
Das ist ein richtiges Paradies hier.
Doch auch im Paradies
muss man Geld verdienen.
Urs wird Pferdehändler.
Nein, da lege ich Geld drauf,
ganz ehrlich.
Was nichts kostet, hat keinen Wert.
Und auch im Paradies muss sich Myriam
ihren Platz erkämpfen.
Ja, Mimi dachtest du,
du kommst hier runter
und das sei
ein Ferien- und Pfadilager?
Nein, das schon nicht.
Die neue Staffel von "Auf und davon",
ab dem 8. Januar auf SRF 1
um 21.00 Uhr.